I was thinking about your path your
journey and I was thinking about how
growing up because I know your your mom
and dad divorce when you're pretty young
they were never married but oh they were
never married but uh yeah so they were
living in sin as we kind of would say I
mean I I honestly I don't even know
their story is so crazy I I don't even
know what was going on but um really
after all these years you still don't
know what was going on
I've heard a lot of different versions
I'll put it that way but um yeah no I I
think yeah they split up when I was
really young so I just I grew up with my
mom right and this interesting thing in
Grapevine Texas yeah and I'm I'm so
what's interesting is that you have
you know anyone who doesn't know your
dad Ravi Shankar you come and and your
mom as well have both have this musical
pedigree this musical background
so
there's some of that but then you're
transplanted to Texas yeah and I think
that's got to be fascinating because you
grew up
um
you grew up in this environment that had
to have influenced you I mean if you had
grown up in New York City
do you know what I mean or in India or
anything with my dad with your dad you
might not be you might not be you at
this moment does that does that make
sense yeah I mean my history is very
different I mean it's interesting
because I'm a musician and he he was he
passed away but he's he was This
brilliant musician Indian musician and
my mom is not a musician but she loved
music so I grew up with my mom seeing my
dad here and there and then not seeing
him for a long period and then we
reconnected later but um growing up I I
was influenced by my mom's record
collection so yeah so who are you
listening to Ray Charles and Aretha
Franklin and
Willie Nelson so this is what's
fascinating so you grow up and you're
listening to those people and you're in
this what what I imagine is this is it a
small town in Texas Grapevine is a huge
sprawling town now but when I was little
it was small right so you're growing up
in this environment and
you were not that connected to the pop
music of your time is that right I was
in Middle School I loved
um Casey Kasem's top 40 every Sunday
like I was obsessed with that for a
while I just listened to Casey I would
turn off the music
I just fell in love with the voice of
Casey
[Laughter]
who's gonna be number one you can you
kind of bootlegs where it's just Casey
and then you don't hear the music I have
all
you were somewhat aware but you were I
guess Jazz was was Jazz a bigger part of
your life it was after a certain point
but I was really into Nirvana and the
Violet Femmes at one point you know and
then maybe like ninth grade I got really
into jazz okay and then that's all there
was for like the next five years that's
all I I was obsessed with I'm so
intimidated by Jazz so a lot of people
are even I am because I'm not really a
great jazz musician it's kind of where I
came from musically
um but I never practiced enough to
really hang with you know real Jazz
musicians
session yeah but that's exactly what
they call themselves yeah I've always
thought of jazz music as you know you're
sitting at the sushi bar and they're
they're like it's Chef's Choice and you
don't know exactly it scares me a little
bit and I and that's just because I have
some mental block I was all about
rockabilly yeah crazy intense rockabilly
and and
um that was the stuff that that pulled
me in
and kind of lit me up you know I just I
inspired me in so many ways uh great
music but very very simple yeah
extremely rudimentary and that was that
was maybe part of the magic for me is it
I could play it I feel you I mean that's
why I I love country songs and sometimes
you just cut straight to the heart of
something with the most simple thing I
think that's
I can't play Fast Jazz either so we're
in it together
yeah and people were always calling me
the Norah Jones of Comedy
um you know I think
that Jim Jones
yeah you're right I'm sorry because I'm
leading my followers yeah well either
way I'm fine either way either way it's
a compliment as far as I'm concerned but
you know what's amazing is that you grow
up listening to these people and then if
you could ever imagine that okay you you
were huge Willie Nelson fan Ray Charles
fan you're going to be playing with
these people you you did a duet with Ray
Charles yeah yeah I did I mean what was
that like what was Ray Charles like he
was very nice you know we went in for
20 minutes we did three takes of the
song and that was it but we were all
live in the room together it was amazing
he was sweet yeah yeah and then uh I
know that you have this much uh longer
lasting connection with Willie Nelson
I've been so lucky to play and sing with
Willie like multiple times I love him so
much yeah he is such a great spirit yeah
did you see they're having a big show at
the Hollywood Bowl for his 90th birthday
in April yeah yeah he is a great
advertisement that marijuana is not bad
for you exactly
uh he he and Snoop Dogg will live to be
600 yeah
you know what's uh what's amazing to me
is I'm thinking about the first time I
met Willie Nelson he came on my late
night show in the early days and he had
that incredible beat up guitar he has oh
trigger trigger yeah that that he's
played forever is it a Martin it's a
nylon string that's a nylon straw I
remember but yeah but he puts it through
an amp yeah he puts it through an amp
which is it's totally cool right he's
got a little drop in uh I think
um uh pickup yeah and he plays it
through an amp and it's got a hole in it
as if it had been recovered somewhere
and a rat had eaten through it not the
sound hole it's got a separate no it's
not a gaping it's got its own there's
the sound hole and then there's this
thing that looks like a ferret plot its
way into the guitar or clawed its way
out uh and um it's covered in signatures
yeah and it's all these people he's had
trigger forever and it's everyone has
signed he he's had all these amazing
people signed trigger and the show's
over and and I said that's just
incredible he's got like George Jones's
signature he's got all these He's got
everybody and there's Tammy Wynette and
there's about all these public and he
said yeah sign it Conan and I said no
we shall not Sully this he's like come
on and he I so I signed it with like a
ballpoint wow oh you did yeah I'm pretty
sure that uh When Willy got backstage he
wiped it off uh yeah that's cool I don't
think I've signed trigger I that was a
dry erase marker exactly he said I said
I'll use my pen he went uh no use this
one wipes off